one minute and 41 seconds of star trek
into darkness with some admittedly great
music but damn does this movie think
it's 2001 followed by a minute and 20
seconds of nothing but credits that do
nothing for nobody
Hey I never realized the next generation
totally stole their theme song from the
original Star Trek movies opening
credits for also Robert Wise you mean
West Side Story and sound a music Robert
Wise seems like the kind of guy I'd get
to direct my science fiction movie
here are three Klingon ships that well
capable of cloaking are approaching this
space thing uncloaked which they
definitely won't regret tactical is
actually standing by on future
afterburner arcade machines typical
Klingon behavior we don't know what this
is let's shoot it the jaws Trek here's
one of the fakest looking spacewalks in
film history and this movie came out
almost a decade after 2001 this is
unacceptable I have an exterior visual
of a fight taking place super far away
Oh
the Klingons are apparently fighting the
ghost of the guitar guy from Mad Max
fury road the ball of electric energy
headed towards the ship is best
represented by a hexagon with six pegs
extending off of it this is when your
computer is given up this glowing ball
of explosiveness is way slower than the
one that took down the other ship a
minute ago
Victory Park this movies planet Vulcan
would seem to be super close to another
large planet with a weird moon that
would seem to deviate from the laws of
OA what the do I care
so when Vulcans have sex do they do it
logically how'd he get a boner that way
a symbol of total logic is illogical
like throwing a virgin sacrifice into a
sex orgy to a piece that cause I feel
like they should have just given him a
copy of the game missed and said you
know what to do and that would end the
ceremony so these assholes were about to
tell SPARC he achieved total logic myths
and give him the symbol of unemotional
reasoning but because the Klingon
murdering space gasps passed by they
found out he still has emotions and take
it back I feel like these dicks should
be stripped of their power for not
noticing this sooner it's amazing these
people live in a world full of matte
paintings and don't suffer some sort of
depression over it their world was lost
but thank God someone painted it back in
the only starship an interception range
is the enterprise because Starfleet
literally keeps only one ship etre its
home base and most important planet even
in 1979 Hollywood could not resist the
nostalgia glamour shot of something
that's not even as cool as the
Millennium Falcon and and did they ever
give you time to stroke it during this
scene
no go ahead this movie is totally giving
you time for that I mean the next shot
is probably inside this ship's wide open
exhaust ports for those who like
close-ups so wait when they park the
enterprise here did everyone onboard
have to fly little ships to the Starbase
after that why is this thing parked all
the way out here four minutes six
brochure for the enterprise ends with
literal penetration at the end of it
something tells me that none of this
ship isn't ready stuff is gonna be
important until the plot demands it is
assemble a crew on the recreation deck
at zero 400 hours on the recreation deck
is this ship not big enough for an
education deck or a were up against big
odds deck do the scary deadly mission
details have to be relayed on the damn
recreation deck that place is for fun
Admiral Kirk
well this is awkward I'm replacing you
as captain of the enterprise
Starfleet made a decision to give Kirk
command of the enterprise without
consulting its current captain in the
matter they felt it better to simply
have Kirk dropped that bomb on Decker in
person well and a good four minutes of
enterprise masturbation to tell him
before Kirk showed up my experience five
years out there dealing with unknowns
like this wait five years that's all I
know the series was canceled early but
that's all the experience it takes to
make a head man desperate is Starfleet
anyway watch out coming through this
ship just can't survive without its
glass Lego box thingamajig
why did they even try to send people
through this transporter thing anyway it
wasn't even considered fixed and they
just send people through that's a
lawsuit right there and weren't they
sending small ships to the enterprise
also what a great way to get Spock back
onto the ship just kill his replacement
in some unnecessary transporter
malfunction yeah
Starfleet do you have them tragic
off-screen transporter deaths are
supposed to remind us of the perilous
nature of human life or the sorry state
of the enterprise or the dangers of oh
who cares
sadness level increased to hutches if we
will just move on what we're captain is
conveniently here to see Kirk get lost
and also to show off his not super
impressive and balls granted this
video of a seemingly Klingon ship being
evaporated by the alien probe is
alarming and scary but who shot that
video the ship that was evaporated was
it live streamed via twitch when it went
missing or something if so how is there
any video of the ship free spacing
wouldn't a tail-mounted camera disappear
with the ship that's all we know about
it except that it is now fifty three
point four hours away from Earth the
alien probe is closer to Earth and the
viewer is to the end of this movie
Enterprise is the only Federation
starship that stands in his way that's
another thing this whole movie is
predicated on the enterprise being the
closest ship to the clown but couldn't
they call any number of ships back use
warp speed and get here in time and not
use a ship badly in need of repair our
orders are to intercept investigate and
take whatever action is necessary why
can't our orders be delivered via ship
wide audio broadcast as normal as
opposed to this everyone gathering a
recreation hall in-person announcement
oh I see it so they can all watch
firsthand while the energy cloud
destroys another vessel external view
but where is camera my oath of celibacy
is on record captain did this check out
of the blue just tell Kirk she's not
gonna have sex with him that's
presumptuous but I guess Kirk throw the
promiscuity is on record tube so maybe
she's covering her bases
Starfleet reports our last six crew
members are ready to beam up but one of
them is refusing to step into the
transporter can't imagine why I mean
just five seconds ago turn two guys into
Plato
guess those bugs got fixed they
transported a few monkeys and now
everything's a-okay
oh my god it's horrible the transporter
is still mangling bodies left and right
and oh that's just bones isn't it
Starfleet spacewalk asshole has time to
do flips waving goodbye to enterprise
even though it deadly energy cloud is
making its way towards Earth party on
Garth after the four-minute wanker thon
involving the enterprise earlier boobie
continues to jack off at a population
over thirty six and a half minutes of
this movie go by before the enterprise
even leaves space dock in the Star Trek
world all our solar system's planets are
super close to each other to create
dynamic visuals over a minute of
wormhole techno babble gibberish but
cameras showing us the wormhole in the
asteroid outside are amazing in clarity
for some reason amazingly check off
obeys even though decker breaks the
chain of command and Kirk who was the
captain does not object if you're
wondering why a two and a quarter hour
movie is so long look no further than
the extended everything everyone sees is
super slow down normalcy why does
blowing up the asteroid take them out of
the wormhole or is that a coincidence by
the way it's simply like Riker and Troy
whom these two clearly inspired the
former captain and the new Helms woman
can't help but be drawn to each other do
their complicated romantic past how the
futuristic scanners account for the
ship's belligerency levels so Enterprise
went into warp hit a wormhole ended up
God knows where then proceeded toward
the target on impulse power and Spock
and his tiny freighter ship were able to
watch all that and put themselves
directly in enterprise's path do I have
that right ah the 70s when you could
only focus on the close up guy and the
guy in the background by blurring out
half the screen thanks to mr. Spock's
timely arrival and assistance we have
the engines rebalanced into full warp
capacity I'm calling it Spock dicks
machina thank God he failed miserably at
logic or point eight
more than 30 seconds of speeding up this
new plot development required Kirk to
put on a new shirt is a hermit holding
on to her workstation during this warp
speed increase because it's looking at
everyone else that is completely
unnecessary and unfit Yuri wouldn't help
much either
I believe it may hold my answers Wow
isn't it lucky for you that we just
happen to be heading your way
bones would be amazing it cinemasins
energy of a type never before
encountered then how can you even read
the existence of said energy you have
scanners that can read energy regardless
of type the new screens held these
screens are so powerful that I don't
want to see the ship have trouble with
an enemy torpedo ever again I mean damn
a previous transmission mode was too
primitive to be received I'm now
programming a hard computers transmit
lingua code at fair frequency and rate
of speed how does raising the frequency
and rate of speed make the primitive
lingua code turn into advanced language
code and how do you increase that you
put the current technology on board we
can't withstand another attack that
thing is 20 hours away from Earth you
know I'm a casual Star Trek fan and I
always thought when people made fun of
William Shatner's line ratings they were
exaggerating but um no they got it right
so here's a four-minute section
completely devoted to flying through
blue and green Apple to graphics and a
collection of reaction shots that are
supposed to instill some sense of wonder
into the viewer but really makes them
wonder if the Empire Strikes Back can
come soon enough people often ask what
makes this movie bad and I often point
to sequences like this but do nothing
but prolong the movie without adding
anything Northern Lights rib cage wait
what
closing on and rapidly captain well you
could have fooled me seriously what the
this is a nearly 1 minute long unbroken
take as they approach the ship in the
middle of the clown I'm adding 20 sins
for this movies inability to cut the
length of its all and wonder shots I'm
pretty sure I've seen these exact Sulu
reaction shots in the previous 10
minutes of nothing this movie calls a
film ditto for the hot bald chick and at
one point during this excruciating ly
long sequence bones walked in for a
moment then walked back out probably
because the filmmakers didn't want to
worry truck fans that he'd died in the
length of time it took to navigate this
alien clown the script here literally
says nothing happens for 10 pages and is
followed by 10 blank pages glowing spiky
exact balls of meaninglessness hurray
for science fiction unnecessary orders
when something finally does happen in
this movie it looks like this not one
person in the crew shrieks in terror
after that Hey look oh it's game back
gave your bones oops there he goes again
my bones hopefully they give you a line
next time is this screen showing blue
spiky things it's more worthless than
the shapeless honeycomb bull screens to
the right the aperture is closing
reverse angle on the viewer captain the
alien ship closes its sphincter
signaling a lack of interest in
interstellar anal sex tractor beam has
released us captain you are now free to
move about the interior of the alien
ship maneuvering thrusters mr. Sulu
ahead one third they are still flying
towards this thing I'm not just being a
snarky asshole when I say this whole
thing could have been cut in half
burl who seemed like a computer the
entire movie comes back possessed by the
alien and still seems like a computer
look just as a practical matter she left
the ship in a Starfleet uniform and she
returned into a sonic shower in a white
mini dress straight out of my preteen
fantasies one thing's for sure this
alien is a teenage boy Jim what's going
on tricorder
I'm the ship doctor but I don't actually
carry a tricorder carbon-based units
humans ensign Perez Jesus who this guy
to get on the ship a thorough
examination of this probe might provide
some insight admit it you just want to
see the sexy Android naked why does an
alien race so advanced to be able to
incapacitate and capture the enterprise
still need to send a humanoid observer
probe thing onto the ship to determine
the fate of its new captain and and this
movie is in love with that double focus
shot with blur all around the edges must
have been new technology at the time or
something this is at least the 47th use
of it in this movie
recorded enough yeah I just needed five
minutes of bull data to complete my job
I'm really glad this unfeeling alien
entity whatever it is decided to keep
Ilias high heels on during the
information gathering process for most
sexiness didn't the probe say she was
done recording is she doing now this is
one of the games floor bass guitar hero
within you are the memory patterns of a
certain carbon unit if I can help you to
revive those patterns you could
understand our functions better that is
logical you may proceed what that is
totally not logical your computer brain
would not allow the possibility that
anything Ilia is still alive at all in
fact you said that unit no longer
functions just a minute ago I'm passing
through a connecting tunnel apparently a
kind of plasma energy conduit who is he
talking to also none of this
dangerous-looking electricity frightens
me in the least as I fly my thruster
suit through I must try to mind-meld
with it can you mind-meld through space
suit gloves though well I guess you can
mind meld with that alien thing through
space suit who know who allowed Kirk to
come out here there are at least three
Starfleet regulations about the safety
of captain's being ignored right now and
we're being robbed at the scene where
someone tried to stop him and Kirk told
him off and triumphant fashion good
thing the unfeeling living machine
decided to somehow spit out the
unconscious Spock to safety the Creator
has not answered the carbon unit
infestation is to be removed from the
creator's planet major never once
considers that the carbon units are its
creator which they ultimately are and
which feature ultimately accepts for no
reason feature is stupid the vessel
feature obviously operates from a
central brain complex obviously one of
those devices reached final position 57
minutes mark they're already in Earth's
atmosphere it's gonna take it goddamn
half an hour for them to get in position
instead of transporting anywhere closer
to the target these assholes go elevator
then spacewalk for maximum film runtime
why did none of you wear a
spacesuit goddamn is there air you don't
know
they've gone way too far in this movie
to ever be in a place where they don't
show the entire walk to Beatrice bring
the G
our feature feature understands the
drama the situation and lets out an
inception grunt of approval wait a
second why does feed your think its
feature based on one little smudgy
nameplate with all its vast knowledge
wouldn't it know that it's Voyager what
part of Beecher's brain casually looked
at a physical nameplate and said yep
that's my name alright time to rule the
universe they know this entire vessel so
that Voyager could actually fulfill its
programming and on its journey back it
amassed so much knowledge it achieved
consciousness itself yeah but what kind
of knowledge was it gathering to become
conscious it's in space it's not like
it's connected to the internet or
something might be able to tell you the
chemical composition Jupiter but it
never got rejected for the prom or
whatever the triggering event is that
makes us ponder the big questions in
life
Beecher speaks but it's less
intelligible than my neighbor's dogs
that's what it's been signaling its
readiness to transmit its information
and there's no one on earth who could
recognize the old signal and send a
response earlier in the movie this thing
was communicating on a frequency that
was so fast the enterprise could not
talk to it because the ship's signal was
too primitive
now they're saying features trying to
use a 300 year old signal after it was
modified in a much better technology
just five minutes from the end this
movies still threatening to put me to
sleep the creature must join with
feature I'm in love with a fake-ass
alien clone of my former girlfriend face
you mean this machine watch to
physically join with a human amazingly
yes that's exactly what this machine
wants to do even though just four
minutes ago its probe said this that is
not logical carbon units are life-forms
yet somehow the machines circled back on
this through all the exposition we just
heard and it will now accept a carbon
life-form as the Creator Captain Vaughn
future pedophile mcdhh a day disappears
in a hail of alien lights and I'm
honestly just ready to go to bed yo and
Beecher was never seen again
it attained the answers to its questions
and moved to a farm in Idaho and had
three Android kits
you'll admit one thing can't beat the
view so what do you like about being up
here
Starfleet do you have them enterprise
what we got back didn't live long and it
exploded of all the souls I have
encountered in my travels yes what's the
most
human
oh here it comes
if we can control it persuaded user I
can do about it in full power and then
have it shut down
you're not gonna get me without a fight
you can't win but there are alternatives
to fighting open the pod bay doors help
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that
I am the keymaster I am the gatekeeper
mr. Sulu ahead warp 1 warp 1 sir heading
sir second star to the right and
straight on till morning